bonjour et bienvenu merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à leurs
besoins ans après que reste t il du
mouvement des filets jaunes je crois que
la caractéristique essentielle du
mouvement des gilet jaune c'est à la
fois ce qui a fait sa force et sa
faiblesse c'est de ne pas être axée sur
un une famille politique particulière et
de ne pas avoir de revendications
spécifiques puis le troisième point
c'est de ne pas avoir de représentant
unique et donc c'est ce qu'a fait sens
on pourrait dire à la fois sa faiblesse
mais aujourd'hui c'est ce qui fait sa
force pour pouvoir le relancer
je pense parce qu'en fait il ya une
revendication et ça a été dit dans votre
précédent sujet il ya une revendication
essentielle je crois qu'on peut la
résumer par une lutte contre
l'infertilité l'infantilisation élitiste
mais quand on a quand les manuels macron
avait fait ce fameux grand débat ce qui
lui a été reprochée c'est que c'était
une sorte d'infantilisation une sorte de
pédagogie en traitant les français en
particulier les français qui ont l'air
d'être les plus faibles comme com com
comme des enfants et donc il remettre en
cause cette infantilisation en dix ans
on peut cependant ma on peut proposer
des choses adapté à la société puis le
deuxième un deuxième grande
revendication c'est la remise en cause
de la mort dit on pourrait appeler ça de
la fiction politique tu souveraineté de
souveraineté du peuple
ils en ont le pape peut vraiment être
souverain il peut être souverain
concrètement il peut se prendre en main
ils devaient se rejoindre définitive je
crois que c'est ce qui fait l'actualité
en réalité aujourd'hui ou d'été gilet
jaune et finalement finalement quels
sont les éléments qui manquent à ce
mouvement pour s'installer de manière
pérenne et se structurer c'est très
difficile répond dans votre question
c'est très difficile parce que si je
veux justement si j'en revenais à la
question des faiblesses je dirais que ça
manque de deux structures
d'institutionnalisation d'idéologie pour
pouvoir exprimer cette idéologie avec
des propositions qui seraient liées qui
aurait une ligne idéologique mais en
même temps 7 7 cette faiblesse je vous
dis c'est ce qui fait la force de ce
mouvement c'est ce qui fait la force de
ce mouvement aujourd'hui donc je crois
que
on peut pas on peut pas comment dire
imposé par le haut une une
ça serait plus ça ne serait plus
d'ailleurs les débats qu'il y avait au
sein même des yeux des jeunes sur la fin
c'était l'idée autant se laisser se
décomposer plutôt que de perdre le pari
initial qui était de laisser monter une
forme d'une nouvelle manière d'envisager
la souveraineté la souveraineté par le
bas donc je sais pas c'est très
difficile
c'est très difficile de vous répondre
c'est l'originalité du mouvement de kif
et sa faiblesse
3 je crois que c'est un mouvement qui
est appelée à à s'imposer au de
l'ajustement des distinctions de partis
qui ont qui semble être de plus en plus
des distinctions en que justement se
représente comme des distinctions
d'élite mais pas des vrais distinction
alors on parle d'un mouvement qui s'est
essoufflé notamment avec la crise
sanitaire
mais il faut il s'attendre à un rebond
des jus des jaunes dans les semaines ou
les mois à venir
est ce que le climat social actuel
justement ne va pas profiter à ce
mouvement
j'ai le sentiment que c'est un climat
qui risque effectivement de profiter à
ce mouvement de profiter pourquoi parce
que justement il y à une sorte de grogne
pays
je vous disais c'est un mouvement qui
lutte contre qui remet en cause plutôt
l'infantilisation élitiste et
effectivement c'est comme si les
décisions le système des décisions
aujourd'hui avait des décisions qui
était infantilisante justement pour la
population qui avait été pris dans o par
un conseil des sages qui serait un
conseil des scientifiques qui serait
seul compétent pour dire pour dire la
vérité avec des politiques etc
donc ça ça entretient enfin que le la
politique contre le virus qui est une
politique qui part vraiment duo qui
entretient cette idée d'infantilisation
et d'une vérité qui viendraient
systématiquement duo est donc sacré
énormément de frustration et donc je
pense que ça laisse de la place pour ce
mouvement effectivement
raphaël liogier merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france je rappelle
que vous êtes sociologue